full power sukuna is way stronger than
we even imagined and our boy satru Gojo
never stood a chance against this
monster how can the heroes of this story
possibly defeat the king of curses that
twist at the very end with Yuji could
actually reveal the only way that sukuna
could possibly lose so let's talk about
it all right now you guys already know
how this works if you enjoy my jjk
content and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment
right now for that YouTube algorithm and
if you want to help this channel attain
special grade status by hitting 2
million subscribers on YouTube do me a
big favor and subscribe right now
finally this video will of course
contain Jutsu Kai's and manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned the previous chapter picked
up after the apparent death of Gojo with
the so-called Thunder God Hajime kashimo
challenging an injured tsukuna to a
one-on-one fight kashimo probably
thought that his chances were pretty
good especially since he was fresh and
he had an incredibly overpowered curse
technique while sukuna had already taken
serious damage from Gojo and his
reserves of reverse cursed energy were
depleted but uraume was able to deliver
a cursed tool to sukuna an item that had
apparently been constructed by yorozu at
first kashimo is fighting effectively
against sukuna and even manages to land
a few blows but then the chapter ended
with sukuna playing his trump card it
turns out that the reason why sukuna
still hadn't attained his forearmed form
yet the form that he was using during
his peak in the heian era is because he
deliberately delayed his full
reincarnation process the completion of
this process and sukuna's transformation
into his forearmed form allowed him to
repair his flesh without using reverse
curse technique he is only able to do
this once which is why he decided to
delay the process in the first place he
was saving his final transfer formation
as his trump card in the final panel of
the previous chapter we saw sukuna
attaining his forearmed form once again
as he prepared to fight kashimot now we
all knew that tsukuna was the favorite
in this fight especially after attaining
his final form but we didn't realize
just how quickly it would all be kashim
over for poor Hajime frat shimo the
latest chapter begins with kashimo
essentially analyzing sukuna and his
cursed energy with his enhanced eyes
kashimo can use his unique curse
technique to reconstruct his flesh in
order to manifest different phenomena
and in this case he seems to be giving
his eyes the ability to see with
something like x-ray vision the narrator
explains that upon getting a good look
at sukuna in his final form kashimo
realizes that he is seeing Perfection
sukuna is not a regular sorcerer he is
literally built different which is what
makes him the perfect Jujutsu Warrior
for example in his final form sukunai is
able to perform hand signs while still
keeping two of his hands free for
fighting since he has four arms he is
also able to manifest a second mouth on
his stomach and this mouth can then
perform chants non-stop without
straining his main mouth and lungs so in
this form sukuna is essentially the
perfect fighter and as you can imagine
even this early on into the chapter the
odds are not looking good for kashimo
back in his prime during the heian era
sukuna accomplished some truly
remarkable and legendary Deeds making
full use of his incredible physique and
his powerful cursed tools he annihilated
the strongest Elite fighters of the
fujiwara clan including the five empty
generals and the sun moon and stars
Squad now of course the fujiwara clan
was the strongest sorcerer family During
the heian period and they were said to
be essentially the true political and
military power in Japan during that time
technically the ruler was the emperor
and the Imperial family but the fujiwara
clan was the true power base and they
regularly intermarried with the Imperial
family in order to ensure their position
on top we know this because the fujiwara
clan in jjk is actually based on the
real fujiwara clan which actually
existed During the heian period in Japan
in our own world sukuna also forced the
Desi chimbu Squad to retreat and this
squad included the most elite fighters
of the Abe Clan and one of its Fighters
was the current culling game participant
Angel finally sukuna defeated the
remnants of the powerful sugiwara Clan
who are the shared ancestors of both
satoru Gojo and Yuta okotsu so yeah
basically sukuna is a legend the best
and most perfect Jujutsu sorcerer in
history he achieved some of the greatest
Feats of the heian era which is in
itself the Golden Age of Jujutsu sorcery
needless to say kashimo is absolutely
Amazed by sukuna the perfect specimen
and the strongest Sorcerer And kashimo
straighta prefers to sukuna as beautiful
this has opened kashimo up to simping
allegations and the dude is definitely
guilty as charged there is absolutely no
doubt about it nevertheless even though
kashimo is a simp he still wants to have
a good fight and so he attacks sukuna
but sukuna uses his forearms to easily
repel kashima's attack and force him
back if you're still not getting the
hint by now sukuna's final form is just
too strong and kashimo simply can't
measure up sukuna prepares to launch a
massive attack at his opponent but he
decides to straight up warn kashimo that
it's coming and he tells him to dodge he
then releases a huge dismantle slash
which kashimo says is the same type of
attack that killed Gojo the attack is
absolutely enormous and it straight up
tears the ground in two luckily for
kashimo he was able to dodge thanks in
part to the fact that he got advanced
warning from sukuna if he hadn't dodged
there likely would have been nothing
left of his body after that overpowered
slash sukuna already realizes that
kashimo doesn't stand a chance against
him so he decides to engage in some
philosophical talk no Jutsu before
ending the fight after all kashimo made
a deal with kanjaku specifically because
he wanted a chance to fight the great
tsukuna so he needs that closure from
the legend himself before he is
inevitably heated out of existence
sukuna is basically kashimo's therapist
let's be honest sukuna says that someone
once told him that he didn't know love
because as the strongest with no equal
he was lonely sukuna is referring to
yorozu here because she wanted to become
his wife and cure him of his loneliness
however sukuna says that she was all
wrong about him and that she should have
been talking to people like Gojo and
kashimo not him go join kashimo felt
lonely because in their eras they were
the strongest with no equal and no one
could come close to understanding them
but sukuna is different he doesn't feel
lonely because he is the strongest the
king of curses then proceeds to
completely outclass kashimo and
hand-to-hand combat eventually he
creates an entire net or like spider web
made up of dismantle slashes and he
sends that massive grid flying right at
kashimot the attack is so wide that it
seems to envelop the entire Horizon and
there is no way for kashimo to avoid it
this attack is the end of the line for
him kashimo is about to die before
kashimo perishes he has like a dying
daydream in which we see him back in his
own time the Edo period some 400 years
ago sukuna shows up and tells him that
there must have been many strong
Sorcerers Who challenged him during this
time and they all wanted to be
acknowledged by him they wanted to find
out who they were and what they were
made of by challenging the strongest and
they were all killed by kashimo sukuna
says that while kashimo claims that he
never understood love and affection and
kindness because no one was as equal in
truth he was loved because he was strong
he was loved and honored by those who
challenged him and he answer to their
Love by giving them a noble and
honorable death essentially sukuna is
saying that being the strongest is not
some curse but rather a great privilege
how can the strongest feel alone when he
is being acknowledged by so many all the
sorcerers Who challenged him over the
years were acknowledging him and they
were all honored to be killed by the
strongest so suguna would say that no
it's not Lonely at the Top it's actually
a privilege kashimo asks whether sukuna
is really satisfied with that because
just like kashimo sukuna himself made a
deal with kanjaku to split his soul and
become a cursed spirit so that he could
live A Thousand Years didn't sukuna
decide to do this because he was waiting
for a worthy opponent to come around in
the future someone like Gojo or maybe
even someone stronger than Gojo sukuna
is just like meh it is because I
understand Concepts like love that I
reject that I don't need other people to
make me feel fulfilled whether it's
people loving me or challenging me in
battle I eat when I wanna eat if someone
annoys me I kill them if I find them
interesting I play with them basically
sukuna just lives in the present moment
he doesn't care about what others think
of him and he is completely free it
almost sounds kind of Zen if you ignored
the parts about him killing people for
fun when kashimo asks him if that ever
gets boring sukuna says no because
humans might be weak and their lives are
short but they are all different and
some of them are very interesting at
this point the talk no Jutsu ends Hajime
is kashim over and we are back on the
battlefield in the present hakari's
domain breaks down and both he and uro
may emerge from the inside on top of
that higuruma and Yuji also show up on
the battlefield and they appear to be
challenging the king of curses directly
sukuna mocks Yuji asking what a brat
like him could possibly do but that's
when we see that Yuji looks like he is
biting his own arm or drinking the blood
out of his own arm and his arm has
pointy demonic nails and fingers just
like sukuna did back when he was
possessing yuji's body and that is how
this insane chapter ends wow this was
Unreal after all that build up and tough
talk kashimo is already dead after
barely two chapters of fighting sukuna
but even though the so-called the
Thunder God definitely disappointed I am
excited to see Yuji back in the game
because he has been sitting on the
sidelines for way too long did Yuji
finally awaken his own curse technique
and is he about to use it on sukuna in
chapter 222 we were led to believe that
he might have some sort of Soul swapping
technique but now I'm thinking that it
could be something else entirely
remember way back in chapter 12 when
Gojo said that in due time yuji's body
would learn to use sukuna's cursed
technique is this what's happening right
now with How Strong full power sukuna
turned out to be maybe the only person
who can actually defeat sukunath is
sukuna and maybe that means that Yuji is
about to use sukuna's own Kirsten
technique against him now that would be
absolutely wild let me know down in the
comments right now if you think Yuji
just awakened sukuna's cursed technique
or maybe some different overpowered
curse technique that will actually allow
him to hold his own against sukuna it
seems unlikely I know but I don't think
gege is just gonna kill Yuji off so Yuji
must have some strategy to fight sukuna
also do you think higuruma could be
important in this battle do you think
that maybe his domain could be super
effective against sukuna because you
can't use violence inside the domain and
tsukuna has committed so many crimes
that he can easily be proven guilty or
do you think sukuna is too strong and he
will just easily destroy the domain
without even needing to follow its rules
honestly man full power sukuna is way
stronger than many of us gave him credit
for and it's hard to imagine how this
absolute monster could lose now unless
Gojo comes back from the dead or
something crazy like that everyone knew
that sukun was the strongest sorcerer in
history on paper but I don't think we
fully understood what that means until
now this man appears absolutely
Unstoppable if you want to learn more
about sukuna his backstory and his
amazing powers and abilities don't
ignore my full video on sukurai and his
true form link on screen and in the
pinned comment if you enjoyed this jjk
video and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like right now and
if you want to help this channel attain
special great status by hitting 2
million subscribers subscribe right now
it's completely free and it helps me out
a lot